let's see who's next what about the 941
area code that's not one that strikes me
is familiar try to you know go to new
area codes whenever possible 941 who's
this hey boy I heard Florida but you've
got maybe the worst connection of any
caller in history so far let's crawl out
of that swamp it's a higher elevation my
apologies I'll try to improve that oh
there we go that's better okay
yeah so it's 85 degrees here and sunny
and breezy beautiful day and grano it's
probably miserable up there I just
wanted to say today Rick Scott current
governor of Florida mm-hm
decided to give a speech for his run to
he wants he's going to run for the US
Senate now right and in his speech he
gave all these statistics about how
there were you know 1.5 million jobs
created and how how the thing is worth
far more but he completely neglects the
fact that in the you know when he took
office seven years ago seven and a half
years ago yeah we were in horrible
recession that Obama fixed and we
created 1.5 million jobs but over 5
million people moved to Florida in his
term interesting and you know so I just
wondered what you thought about Rick
Scott right who is was done nothing for
Florida he didn't take the Medicaid
expansion 3 billions of dollars refused
that cut taxes for the rich and for
businesses and literally hasn't done
anything for the people of Florida so I
just wanted to hear your thoughts about
listen I'm not a big rick Scott guy I
think economic statistics as we talked
about earlier in the week are complex in
the sense that you know the what was the
back where you're pointing out something
really important which is what was the
background rate of job creation relative
to the job creation rate in Florida how
does the job creation rate in Florida
compare to the population increase in
Florida and thus the unemployment rate
in Florida you know these you deal with
some of these issues of
of the the economics of some of these
bills in terms of Medicaid expansion and
the state choosing not to do that I'm
not a rick Scott fan and the
transportation and transportation which
is a big thing actually in in southern
states which often are have
opportunities that they turn down and in
terms of public transportation and and
rail and many others I think that the
guy is basically a charlatan but I think
that with any of those economic
statistics not saying that he's right or
wrong but it's good to just look into
them in more detail and to understand
some of the other things that are going
on contextually but what if you're at
question is what I vote for the guy the
answer is no between him and Ben Nelson
Nelson yeah absolutely
yeah yeah he's he's he's horrible
I didn't want to say you know appreciate
take my call and you know it's a
beautiful day and I know Europe and
Boston right yeah well I'm gonna don't
worry I'll be back down in Miami before
you know it at the rate that I'm trying
to get back down there very very soon so
I appreciate the reminder yeah yeah
agrees down there right now
good yeah have a great day and you know
just remember everyone you know whenever
a politician gives statistics yes their
statistics they're not mentioning right
so you know looking do your own research
for sure very very much appreciate the
call and the reminder about how
different parts of the country have
different weather yeah I make fun of
Florida because I love Florida but that
is why that transportation thing kills
me so much is I would love to be able to
get on a train and go from Miami to
Orlando to Jacksonville and kind of get
around easily without needing a car for
sure and so that would have helped not
only the construction jobs obviously in
the people that would run that system
yeah but it would have helped tourism
yeah absolutely absolutely this is shame